think did I get turned around I might
have gotten turned around because
yeah sometimes when the camera snaps it
turns me
hello everybody my name is Markiplier
welcome back to input six
I'm here to finish the game because I
want to know the mystery of the robo
maid
very interesting very captivating in in
some ways okay so that was the
everything's terrible letter
this is a weird portrait
uh-huh
top left part burned oh William J Price
William graft strange
ah interesting
okay highly awaited by many Tech Aid
robotics Premiere event took place
yesterday on September 9th 1993 less
than a month after its announcement the
company revealed their newest invention
robotic assistant mayday
we gathered all information given to us
on the event and present them to you in
this special edition of Technology world
it's hard to believe after so many years
past disclosure decade brand returns now
is decade robotics one exciting comeback
it is most of the guests at the event
were now ready to see the company's
newest invention robotic home assistant
Mayday but with the Grandville Mayday
came a lot of questions and doubts
regarding never before seen Technologies
installed in it that would be concerning
okay you guys can pause and read this if
you would like
there's a lot here to read
um
okay and a manual getting started with
Mayday okay good machines must be
inspected every three months in
specialized license facilities that's
needy list of items May Day huh
perceptive folks probably already
figured out the word play in the name
yep
Mecha electronic autonomous interactive
Aid powered by artificial intelligence
wow
camera is in the neck where's the camera
in the neck that seems like a horribly
inefficient place to put the camera
whatever booting up executing command
sleep mode alert mode
charging the battery to charge the
battery afterwards depletion follow the
instructions set the robotic assistant
in a sitting position remove its
clothing
remove its back case plate as shown
below connect battery when fully charged
it's connected with the cover plate back
on the clothes back on the robotic
assistant that is a step in this
procedure I see
interesting okay so what I'm going to do
is we're going to be doing this again
and I'm going to get a better
understanding of the layout of the space
now that I know if for sure that each
input is a different location I'm gonna
have a better ability to be able to get
where I need to go
input six I don't need input six I need
input one
okay
so it is fairly obvious
what the device okay it actually gave a
diagram of the device that is helpful
whoa hi
so if I can just
a better
understanding
oh the beep is not helping me beep is
not there to help me
the beep is only there to mislead me it
has been way too long since I saw why is
this different
[Music]
that's not fair if you're gonna change
where I am did I just go down a
different hallway for some reason
did I somehow just go down a different
hallway
oh boy I don't like being backed in the
corner like well that's problematic
oh God
oh
well who needs color right am I right
everybody I'm so right
never been more right in my life
oh wow that's not quality
sure would be a shame if uh
maid snuck up on me out of nowhere
and abducted the soul right out of my
body
that'd be that
okay
at least it is giving me more time I I
feel like this is much less frantic than
it was before
I say right before I have someone
sprinting up my ass
is that it no oh god oh I know this one
uh
oh my God
that was way too close okay whoa okay so
long as I got my good reactions I'm
gonna be able I'm gonna be able to make
it that's a cup that's not what I need
frick
uh
I'm still not ooh I'm still not getting
a good sense of the space here
oh this is where it threw me off into
another dimension this is still the same
I'm still in the offices and put to his
offices currently
some could whoa so it's getting more
frantic
okay that's where I started
no
kind of looked like it might have been
but it was not
it's a cafeteria again
okay so I was going right from the
cafeteria I went into the locker room oh
I'm trying to map this out of my head
usually I'm pretty good with directions
but jumping from space to space like
this is not helping in any way so I went
in here from one side
it is entirely possible that it's here I
don't think there's a light on it
there might be a light on it I have no
idea
uh there we go
there might be a light on it I don't
know
okay so I checked all of here but I
don't remember which dual door I came in
okay so I just went in there
I don't remember which direction I came
from
oh it was this way
almost fast forwarded into my demise
but in here
okay it's been a while since I've been
here this is the office one offices so I
went in one set of offices I did not go
in the other
this is a different office oh oh oh
my God okay I just gotta keep moving I'm
not gonna go over to input six and look
at it because that would be a dumb dumb
move I ain't a dumb dumb I'm not gonna
be a dumb dumb about this
oh oh okay that's one I've got ten
minutes left to find the rest and
there's only so much space to be able to
search at a warehouse I'm in a warehouse
I'm in a warehouse I'm in a warehouse I
just came off of doing uh I'm on
observation booty so I feel like my
spatial recognition is at as good as
it's gonna be
which is not saying it's great but it's
as good as it's gonna get
whoa okay I don't remember where I was
wig wig room whoa that was too soon okay
this is where I went backwards I need to
not go backwards the exit signs are
pointing to where I don't need to go
there's a big Factory here I have not
been in
no
okay I'm coming out of here because I
want to check these small individual
rooms first
and then I'll go to the other end of the
big Factory and there's a door out that
way
hello input six I'm not ready for you
okay
I'm going past the scaffolding I'm not
going in the red well never mind I'm not
going anywhere
okay I'm in the middle of the big
Warehouse
water canisters there
still exploring
this room have not seen the fullest I
more than likely it's going to be
somewhere where there's a bunch of desks
or something like that
I think
um
this okay I'm gonna go through this door
could be something in here videotapes
nothing
okay in the wig room so wig room is good
and another hallway
oh
okay I'm done with the power room I'm
going out of the power room here oh my
brain okay I went in there I've been
through the that factory I'm going
through each individual room before
looping back to the factory so that I
can see
I'm going not in the Red Room okay I'm
going here first
this might be where I started I can't
quite remember but there's a bunch of
small individual things here
damn it
okay got it okay I'm looking for things
like this area here where there's
benches and desks most likely it's going
to be there I have no idea check in this
back room wait let me check this Inner
Room here first it might be a bathroom
no it's a hallway damn it
well I saw you all right so I went in
here going through here again
wigram
I was cutting back in so I could start
looking at the inner rooms in here
okay wow
I wouldn't be able to see anything in
there anyway
no let me try these individual rooms
first
this is unfortunate
whoop
keep going
around the corner here
into the interims I think I've ran the
perimeter of this space I don't really
know where else
it could be
I haven't been in here
oh
I've been in there that's where I first
went in to explore that area I think I
came in through there
let me cut across and keep going in the
freaking okay I remember the ticking
keep going on this one
did I get turned around I might have
gotten turned around because
yeah sometimes when the camera snaps it
turns me oh my God
could be in here
I got it
uh I might have checked this already I
don't if I just don't know
okay this is promising
big open room another problem huh
oh boy well I wasn't using fast forward
anyway so what does it matter
okay
do I have a flashlight why don't I have
a flashlight
why don't I have a flashlight
why no flashlight
beep
oh my God these places are just huge
wonderful
oh come on
oh ass ass
oh wait whoa oh holy oh my God
oh my God I got it oh well my vision's
still wonkified but it's okay
oh my God
okay well input six I'll be back with
you in a second as much as I would love
to see the beautiful delicious lore
uh I don't have whoa I don't have time
right now did it turn me around again oh
please tell me it didn't turn it did not
turn me around again
okay good
this is uh good though too
of five
okay it's not good but you know it's
better it's better than one which is all
I had before and I'm back to where I
started
damn it dang nabbit
Okay so
okay so unless this was the big circle
and I'm dumb well I'm dumb
okay so I was in here looking around in
here oh please don't do this
oh God please
yeah I cannot play like that whoo
still going forward
okay
so I got called Logan there I am still
trying to go this way
oh no I came through here that's right
maybe there's another way through this
uh big Warehouse thing
like this way
okay this is this is this is different
this is different
oh
where is this
I don't remember where this was
[Music]
okay there's explodies I don't remember
seeing that though oh God it's dark
oh my God why is it so dark down that
hallway
okay but that is a dead end maybe that's
what the bomb indicates it's like one
far end of the certain space
could be something
and in there
and in all these actually
huh
no that's a cup
I've seen that definitely
okay no I got pulled into looking come
on you're not gonna give me anything
oh no I've been there
oh boy
oh boy okay all right tile floor
somewhere there I got pulled in
oh man I keep getting turned around
and whoa oh my God okay I think my I
think I might be done so
oh my God hi
see I didn't think I got caught there
but apparently I did
good
[Music]
okay this is definitely edge of a map
yeah edge of map for sure for sure so
this is one edge of the map that's one
way to know
so I think the idea probably is just try
to make it to one edge of the map so
that you can definitely cross it off and
work backwards from a place that you can
most definitively remember
that is helpful
it keeps wanting to put me right in
there
so this is a dead end
this is all a dead end have I not gone
anywhere I can never go in there
what about over here have I gone over
here I don't think I've gone over here
no no definitely not Oh I thought that
was it I thought that was hurt oh why
thank you
oh no oh no
hi
[Music]
time's up
but that's okay that was just the first
attempt back and I've already improved
and I'm getting a better understanding
of where exactly everything is so I
started from here on input one starts
from here
it's definitely not going to be here so
I just went in a big circle
but because I know this space
a little better
so I'm just gonna go
to the corner so that I can cross it off
the list and say for sure it's not over
here
good good good good okay so I'm starting
in the conference room here not in here
oh my God
okey dokey then
I just need to pick a direction and go
that way
once I hit the end of the space
I'll Circle back later
okay big ass room could it be on one of
the inner shelves here that would be
annoying
not on these shelves
great
that's good
oh whoops God damn it I meant to Sprint
and I didn't
okay
tile area is different
let's stay in the tile area never mind
okay scrap pile starting from a scrap
pile first go right
then go left
wait was there another door on the right
over here
wait there was another everything on the
right over there
some of these some of these Circle up on
themselves
it's hard to say which ones it should be
shower no Workshop oh I've never seen
this I have seen this I've seen this
I've definitely seen that before whoa my
God okay
I was I went there I established the
back there that's what I did there whoa
okay that's fine
okay establish this when the bathrooms
check every stall
okay stalls are good someone's taking a
tinkle
[Music]
oh God
okay I was going in here I was going
into these
never mind
ah okay interesting
um fascinating
I have not been able to make much
progress on this guy
because this is where I started
okay started there
definitely no need to be there
on the red area
the circles back and connects back over
here never mind it doesn't connect to
the other side but it's fine
nothing here
[Music]
God damn it okay I'm getting mixed up
no what that actually does connect up in
the pitch Darkness
oh my God no
oh my God it do oh my God it do
it
oh hold up found one all right that's on
one that's on one okay got input ones
thing are they in the same spot they
would not be in the same spot would they
are they in the same spot
that seemed familiar
wow I didn't even hear the approach I
just saw my gamer kind of froze
and also I think it's a better strategy
to just be sprinting and fast forwarding
all over the place relying on your
instincts to save you when needed
great thank you thank you so much
thank you for that thank you
keep making it to the same place how do
I do that
I hate this one
[Music]
I literally keep circling back to the
exact same places
it's like something you could probably
analyze my behavior and tell me why but
um
oh hi
hello
how are you
yeah you could probably tell me why but
I don't know if I want to know
I keep thinking like oh no I'm
definitely well um
I'm definitely going somewhere new but
uh no it turns out no it turns out I'm
just dumb
turns out I'm just dumb and going
soyukouls
[Music]
and I'm going in circles
hi
good hi
all right I see I'm running out of time
I get it I get it you don't need to tell
me twice
great
what if I just apply the maze rule to
this if I just keep making left turns
won't I always make it if I just keep
making left turns make every left turn
possible no no I'm going in a circle I'm
trapped in a loop didn't realize amazes
do that my plan was flawed
okay Edge there
oh great
[Music]
oh I saw you
keep making it to the same shower how do
I keep going to the shower how
how do I keep doing that
I have no idea it doesn't make any sense
how does one want to shower so deeply
my heart yearns for the shower
homemade
could you find me in the direction of
the shower
I'd be helpful that'd be so incredibly
ill I found it
[Music]
it was by the shower all along well
egg on my face I was wrong all along
fascinating
maybe it's something like the proximity
by with which you get attacked is
indicative of how close you are to that
thing I don't know why that one was dark
why was why was that that screen just
darkness
I didn't like it
one of these all have to look like the
damn thing oh hi
interesting okay this is kind of new
ish haven't seen this yet hi I've seen
you
and back in the offices ah if I remember
it was actually in the office last time
I did this I don't know why it took me
so long to even get to the office but
hey
that's just a theory
oh who's in the offices
oh
oh joyous day fracture steak look away
oh my God
no way
oh my God I'm just gonna look at this
because I whoa that I don't look happy
um
uh Mayday you
you oh
well 55 seconds I don't have any time at
all
I'm never gonna make it it's dork why is
it dork it's just dark oh my God
oh ow my bones
oh it's just are you kidding me am I
done did I get four did I get four
no
I was just goofing a bro okay I was just
goofing around when I could have had it
oh
I could have had did it did if I hadn't
been goofing so hard no
oh
no
oh it's a cup of coffee I thought I had
it oh
oh
wow oh it's so close
close
one more try I should be able to get it
you can make the game a bit easier or
more challenging screw you I
I got it I'm on it I'm in it to win it
and I'm on it
so ready
so whoa
so ready so ready
I need to find the offices here I think
I'm willing to bet
God damn it
no
frick
you sack up poop
are you gonna be like that
when speaker was broken on this one
anyway why do I care
oh it's better now
well that one wasn't so bad
there's more Offices here
Oh I thought that phone might have been
it already well that would have been
wonderful sadly no
oh my God is that it oh my God that's it
oh my God that's it God you ass
all right but I'm right there
I was right
why does it seem like the same one
no it's never there
okay this is what I was I was looking
for the one in this one before and I was
not finding it
oh frick
those minigames are tough
but I'm tougher
I can get this
no match for me
I'm a huge brain huge brain actually
gigantic it's massive even
was that the thing
was that the thing oh my god did I just
see the thing
I think I just saw the thing
oh
I think I've got eyes right next to two
things
it wasn't in here that I just saw the
thing no it was in the next one I just
saw the thing in the next one
okay but that's where I came in from
not in here damn not gonna get an easy
office one this time
it's okay don't need it don't need it
don't need it
crowbar this is the Crowbar mean
anything or are there any environmental
Clues don't need them because I got that
one that's all I need oh yes please
yes please oh my God it's right there
yes
okay so that's two with 11 minutes left
and I've already made a good bit of
progress
going through here
what I pressed it
there we go
okay look around the printing presses
nothing jumping out of me
it doesn't seem to be in there
anywhere in here
okay
oh my God how did you get me I thought I
didn't get got I got God
turns out I was got is that it
oh my God what is happening
what
what what no
what do you mean game over what
what do you mean I was doing so good
no why
why did it came on
I wasn't ready for the game over
I was I was doing so good
well I was doing so good
why did it game over
don't game me over
I don't get it
I was doing so good
oh my God hi okay I get it when that
happens
because you know I get caught and that's
how it used to be you know you get
caught and you go ah and then you let me
go
put me in the timeout scrap pile for a
little bit and then I I go home
I thought that's how it was supposed to
be
oh
my God that's that would have been easy
to miss okay so yeah I'm coming out of
the timeout scrap pile
I keep thinking that cup is it but it's
not and I get that
foreign
the problem is there are two bathrooms
wait no no there aren't wait
am I crazy or is there
I didn't hear it at all
I don't know what that one does if you
fail it I have no idea
I've swear I'm just looping back in the
same ones here
I don't know how but I am gotta break
out that's the one thing that I've found
kind of works is that if I just
desperately try to go as physically far
wherever I am and whatever I'm doing
like just get out just go far if I can
just go far away
at least that'll break me out of the
cycle of just looping back and forth
which is what gets me killed all the
time
it gets me stuck and then I can't move
anywhere and then I'm nothing and then I
die
so just get far
and I'm back here
how does that happen
just get far I just like it's just when
it rips you in a certain direction
[Music]
like how am I supposed to know this
hallway goes if I keep going straight on
this how far does it go
that's how far
what
oh hi I'm in timeout oh I'm in timeout
maybe that's what happened is
um if you only have one dude left or
less or a few dudes if all of them get
into timeout uh it might be game over
that that might have explained it
oh my God
I don't even have a timer on this one
I think I'm just dead
oh oh oh it was in this tiny offshoot
room okay well I'm still doomed with two
and a half minutes
but at least I'm getting my bearing
slightly
slightly okay so this is a dead end room
basically what that is where that shower
is it's it's a side room that has no
other paths to it
that if I remember that is useful
information
this is obviously a tape room that
connects this with the other side
and that leads to here and then a
bathroom Maybe
oh God I didn't mean to do that oh my
god well oops
not my objective
and this I already looked in here it
must just be I I'm willing to bet that
it's just there's another
shower there are two showers on either
end of this unless it just loot it how
did that Loop that
doesn't make sense does the geogu
geography change
this is a dead end
how did I get back here I literally came
through here
went through here I did this
I literally unless it's just a goddamn
mirror
is that why it's so confusing
God damn it
it's it's a freaking mirror
I hate that all right I got it I got it
I got it
I got it I got this i got this i got
this
start on one end know that I've looked
at one end of this even if it's a mirror
Ender whatever
they're founded okay that's great holy
crap
start in here
oh my god I've never found one that fast
that is insanity
might have a shot on this one might
might have a shot
who knows
okay I don't know what was going on
there
that was strange
and a clocker
if I remember last time I did this one
it was some random ass little alcove
that anyone could have missed and I
definitely did
that looked like it was part of it but
it wasn't
but the answer seems to be that this is
a random spawn and by just going
to the far ends of the Earth for this
stupid thing
I will make it
and I will get it because who knows
where it could be I just gotta travel
the distance and cross my fingers and
kiss my ass goodbye
two I gotta look for the offices
his office is around here somewhere
oh
oh my God
there are two showers on this one
I swear to God every time I come in here
I swear this it Flippy floppies
that's close to spawn I don't think oh
well
hell wow
yeah I don't think that I'm
gonna get what I need there
just gonna get out of here
I keep getting caught up in this room
for ages and ages and it's not where I
need to be
I know that
oh great
oh oh
input two where are these goddamn wolf
every time I think I'm gonna make
progress and then you stop me
well
hi
oh my God you are being so active two
offices this way
it was the other way
I see that now
[Music]
it did it it did it it did change it
it does change if you go in this goddamn
bathroom and you come back out it's
different I caught you red-handed
what is with that
I missed that completely
what is with that I thought I was going
out of my mind
I was right
it does change why would you do that
why would you be so horrifically evil
why would you wake up and choose
violence
so there must be in all of these levels
in all of these there is one thing that
does cause you to loop back and I don't
know why
but it do it'll Loop you back
which is really inconvenient
it's horrendously inconvenient for you
to yes please thank you
oh my God it was dark out there oh God
please I need this
oh God no no no no I'm losing it no no
no no please yes
okay
I can't get caught with everybody
that's for sure this is about to do it
again whoa
I thought I was crazy for so long I
thought I was crazy that
oh hello
[Music]
oh my God is it just the one left
oh no
oh my God it's just the one left and I
have seven minutes to get this but I
cannot
I cannot get caught
if I get caught on this character
is game over right
that's how this goes
nailed it
damn it I'm just going back in circles
again
that's okay watch I'll go in this
bathroom and it'll be very different
when now immediately
don't know why don't know how but it is
different wasn't it in oh
my God that's it that's it oh my God I
did it I did it
where am I what am I doing
what
I'm on input six I'm playing input six
what does that mean
am I the one that's chasing everyone
else now
[Music]
where am I
oh not that way
oh I'm on the level above
oh that's weird
so I can't go through here
where did you want me to go
I can't fast forward either
this is just back the way I came
no I must miss something
okay input six oh oh oh
that was kind of hard to see
oh
hi
[Music]
thank you
um
I'm alive
you seem to be dead
no just impaled
oh never mind Dad okay yep all right
oh
hi
you wave oh you're not waving you're
calling at me okay that's that's there
okay
well you're so malicious against one of
your own I'm assuming that's what I am
oh that's sad
oh
I see
new record added to archives new game
mode unlocked
I win
freedom
hopefully the beeping doesn't mean that
another bomb is about to go off
did no one else notice the big explosion
anyone in this neighborhood
cricket's chirping
oh
well that was great
that was awesome
I love that
that was really cool Mayday we have a
problem company with no future
catastrophe today wow
well that is unfortunate for them but
they shouldn't have been playing with AI
robot Maids that's think that's a listen
to us all so thank you everybody so much
for watching I'm glad I could beat this
it was quite fun it was different at
first going back again and really like
getting with it the one thing that took
me so long is how it teleported you how
unfair is that no wonder it felt like I
was going to the same exact place over
and over again it freaking teleports you
you go in the bathroom and then suddenly
you're somewhere else just don't go in
the bathroom I guess is the only answer
to that well
thank you let me know what you thought
down in the comments below and I did
like this game it was a very different
style of game I've never played anything
quite like it and I'd love to see an
evolved concept of this because it's
just really really cool so thank you for
making it check the link in the
description for the link to the game and
let's see if there's another one coming
around the corner thank you and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]